il y a un an et demi après l'élection du
gouvernement minoritaire de pauline
marois un des premiers gestes du
ministre de la métropole jean françois
lisée avait été d'aller rencontrer la
communauté anglophone de la région de
montréal or nos collègues de la cilicie
ont voulu mesurer l'humeur des
anglophones d'ici ils allaient voir
plusieurs se disent disons moins heureux
qu'il y a trois ans reportage plusieurs
aime encore le québec mais ont tout de
même envie de le quitter
j'aime montréal
mais depuis trois ans cette envie de
vivre ailleurs est resté stable chez les
francophones
mais elle a beaucoup augmenté chez les
anglophones et les allophones
un sondage ekos menée auprès de plus de
2000 personnes indique qu'un anglophone
sur deux a songé à partir au cours de la
dernière année comparativement à 35 pour
cent au cours des trois dernières années
chez les allophones c'est la même
proportion soit 49% qui a songé à
quitter le québec au cours de la
dernière année
c'était 28 % au cours des trois
dernières années
pour les anglophones les débats
identitaires donne très souvent
l'impression que ils sont pas inclus
puis c'est surtout à cause de la loi de
pauline marois qui essaient de la mettre
en pot sa cause c'est ça qui qui nous
pousse à faire ça puis en même temps les
autres provinces du canada comme ontario
etc
il nous invite à venir j'aime bien en
france est sérieusement moi j'adore le
québec pour ça mais si on m'oblige à
quitter le pays parce que je porte le
voile ou peu importe
et bien sûr je la quitterais les raisons
évoquées sont maintenant plus liées au
climat politique qu'au contexte
économique
chez les anglophones les certitudes
politiques l'emploi l'économie et
l'intolérance sont les principales
raisons pour les allophones
il y a le climat politique et l'économie
mais aussi la barrière linguistique
d'autres sont moins inquiets maria
l'histoire
vraiment intéressant et compliqué et
c'est bon pour moi c'est phone donc les
problèmes ce n'est pas un problème pour
moi
ces changements d'humeur ne se sont pas
encore traduit concrètement dans le
marché immobilier par exemple mais ce
sont des signes qui sont susceptibles
d'attirer l'attention des politiciens
ici anne louise despatie radio canada
montréal